[The Universe in Verse]
[Prelude]
In 1908,
Henrietta Swan Leavitt,
one of the women known
as the Harvard Computers,
who changed our understanding
of the universe
long before they could vote,
was cataloging photographic plates
at the Harvard College Observatory,
single-handedly analyzing
2,000 variable stars --
stars with fluctuating brightness,
kind of like a lighthouse beacon --
when she began noticing
a distinct correlation
between their brightness
and their blinking pattern.
That correlation made it possible
to measure the distance of stars
for the very first time,
furnishing the yardstick of the universe.
Meanwhile, a dutiful
teenage boy in the Midwest
was repressing his childhood
love of astronomy
and beginning his legal studies
to fulfill his dying father's demand
for an ordinary, reputable life.
When his father died,
Edwin Hubble turned that passion
for the stars into formal study
and discovered two revolutionary
facts about the universe:
that it is tremendously
bigger than we thought
and that it's getting bigger
and bigger by the blink.
One October evening in 1923,
perched at the foot
of the largest telescope in the world,
at Mount Wilson Observatory,
not far from here,
Hubble took a 45-minute
exposure of Andromeda,
which was then thought to be one
of many spiral nebulae in our Milky Way.
The notion of a galaxy,
a gravitationally bound cluster
of stars and dust and dark matter,
didn't exist at the time.
The Milky Way, which, by the way,
was coined as a term
by Chaucer in the 14th century,
was thought to be
what was called an "island universe"
beyond the edge of which lay
cold, dark nothingness.
But when Hubble looked
at the photograph the next morning
and compared it to previous ones,
he furrowed his brow
and with a gasp of revelation
scribbled right on top of the plate "VAR"
and then drew an exclamation point
because he had realized
that a tiny fleck in Andromeda
previously thought to be a nova
could not possibly be a nova,
given its blinking pattern
across these different photographs.
And it was, in fact, a variable star.
Which meant, given
Henrietta Leavitt's data,
that it was very, very far away,
farther than the edge of the Milky Way.
Which meant that Andromeda
was not a nebula in our own galaxy,
but a whole other galaxy,
out there, in the cold, dark nothingness.
Suddenly, the universe was a garden,
blooming with galaxies,
with ours but a single bloom.
That same year, in another country,
suspended between two World Wars,
another young scientist
came up with the radical idea
of using rocket technology,
this deadly military technology,
to mount an enormous telescope
and launch it into Earth's orbit.
Not only closer to the stars,
but bypassing the atmosphere
that occludes our terrestrial instruments.
It would take another
two generations of scientists
to make that telescope a reality:
a shimmering poem of metal,
physics and perseverance
bearing Hubble's name.
But when the Hubble Space Telescope
launched in 1990,
our human fallibility had slipped
into the precision of the instrument,
and it turned out that its primary mirror
was ground into the wrong spherical shape,
warping these long-awaited images
of the unfathomed universe.
Up the coast from
Mount Wilson Observatory,
a teenage girl watched her father,
who had worked on the Hubble,
one of NASA's first Black engineers,
come home brokenhearted.
He didn't know that his observant daughter
would become poet laureate of his country
and would commemorate him
in the tenderest tribute
that an artist's daughter
has ever composed for a scientist father,
which would win her the Pulitzer Prize
the year the Hubble's corrected optics
captured that revolutionary,
ultra-deep field image
of the observable universe,
revealing what neither Hubble
nor Henrietta Leavitt could have imagined.
That ours is not just one
of several galaxies,
but that there are 100 billion
galaxies out there,
each containing 100 billion stars.
Narrator: From “My God,
It’s Full of Stars.”
When my father worked
on the Hubble Telescope, he said
They operated like surgeons:
scrubbed and sheathed
In papery green,
the room a clean, cold and bright white.
He’d read Larry Niven at home,
and drink scotch on the rocks,
His eyes exhausted and pink.
These were the Reagan years,
When we lived with our
finger on The Button and struggled
To view our enemies as children.
My father spent whole seasons
Bowing before the oracle-eye,
hungry for what it would find.
His face lit-up whenever anyone asked,
and his arms would rise
As if he were weightless,
perfectly at ease in the never-ending
Night of space. On the ground,
we tied postcards to balloons
For peace. Prince Charles married Lady Di.
Rock Hudson died.
We learned new words for things.
The decade changed.
The first few pictures came back blurred,
and I felt ashamed
For all the cheerful engineers,
my father and his tribe. The second time,
The optics jibed.
We saw to the edge of all there is --
So brutal and alive
it seemed to comprehend us back.